[Musique]
mais gilbert couturier bonjour bonjour
monsieur carrusca oui alors vous êtes
maire du gros morne
vous êtes maire sortant et vous avez
décidé de vous représenter après une
mandature qui a été notamment marqué
gilbert couturier par une forme d'
absentéisme au sein du conseil municipal
vous avez même dû vous adresser à
l'ensemble des élus en janvier 2017 pour
une espèce de jeu passée de rappel à
l'ordre mais en tout cas pour au moins
une clarification de situation et cela
ne vous a pas dissuadés de de vous
représenter d'être candidat à votre
propre succession
alors je crois que c'était une
expérience eu une bonne expérience
humaine pour avoir avant d'être élu à
intervenus et une semaine territoire
tant sur les actions sociales
économiques et je vais 10 ou
accompagnement de justiciables donc je
crois que j'étais une bonne aventure
est ce que cela pouvait me dissuade il
le fait de pouvoir entrer en fonctions
avec des élus qui pour la première fois
tout comme moi même avait cette mission
et puis pouvoir comprendre le
fonctionnement véritablement nous
conseil municipal et en particulier les
jeunes qui ont un emploi ou dans les
chronos aurait on a défini le contenu
le du conseil de la convocation du
conseil vous n'êtes pas toujours évident
de pour eux de pouvoir arriver à lui
puisque avec la circulation les
embouteillages tout cela je suis pas des
excuses je veux aussi dire qu'il ya déjà
eu un contexte particulier parce que ce
sont des conseillers municipaux de votre
groupe de votre majorité qui n'était pas
là certains ont même démissionné ensuite
et et au delà de ces démissions dans
votre groupe
il y en a même qui se retrouve
maintenant concurrents face à vous sur
d'autres listes c'est pas moi par
exemple qui sont allés rejoindre l'un de
vos concurrents monsieur vaugirard c'est
la loi de la démocratie
et puis j'aime pour donner comme
métaphore la langue et les d'un son de
sont logés à la même enseigne ça arrive
qu'il y ait des accidents être la langue
et les dents
donc je vois pas ou fait comment dans la
cohabitation et peut pas avoir de
différence mais je crois que vous faites
sauter impôts autant les électeurs les
concitoyens gonnin qui nous écoutent ce
qui les intéresse c'est de savoir au
fait qu'est-ce que pendant cette
mandature j'ai pu le rapport aux ti
alors précisément vos détracteurs vos
concurrents pas tout le monde au gros
morne mais certains donc vous accuse
d'une certaine forme d'inertie de ne pas
avoir tenu vos promesses notamment
concernant les réflexions de l'église et
du marché et puis vous êtes également
accès de ne pas savoir monter les
dossiers qu'est ce que vous répondez à
ces détracteurs je réponde aux fêtes aux
gens qu'ils épisode se trouvait trop
loin et de la réalité de la vie gonese
malgré que les conseils municipaux et
les unions tenu les vendredis de la
place dès samedi des sites et les
mélodies des quartiers des unions public
qui se sont tenues tout au long de la
mandature et biens ou ordonner des
informations pour du comment des choses
avancer et que pour l'église
donc il faut que les gros mornais
s'informe davantage continue entre les
cas pour ceux qui disent que rien ne se
sont ennuyés ne s'est passé pendant six
ans non mais l'église et le marché c'est
terminé
c'est fait ou pas non je pense que vous
vous dites beaucoup de choses mais
prenez le temps d'écouter ce que je vais
vous expliquer pour dire ça c'est facile
non j'ai pas dit ça je pose des
questions ce qui se dit c'est vraiment
ce qu'il faut retenir lorsque constitue
un dossier notamment pour une église
pour une église et que ce bâtiment qui
est resté à l'abandon pendant l'homme de
temps bâtiment kg les commentaires de
2007 a été affectée et que l'assurance a
ordonné pour l'ensemble des bâtiments
notamment pour l'église quatre cent
trente mille euros soit 420 millions
pour l'église et que cet argent je fais
aussi demandé à ceux quittant
responsabilités en charge de
l'aménagement du territoire
quand il fait avec cet argent là où les
concitoyens les gens qui utilisent
église et à l'est et plusieurs fois il
ya trois rapports faisant injonction au
maire en place de pouvoir mettre à
l'abri les gentils fille quant à
l'église
alors nous avons pu d'abord faire ce
bâtiment entrées dans le patrimoine des
bâtiments de france
mais pour pouvoir le faire il fallait
aussi trouver le titre de propriété
parce que ce bâtiment n'est pas de titre
de propriété deuxième chose à voir les
subventions mais une fois que ça a été
classée 2 qu'il fallait faire là
dimanche pour le budget des subventions
coutu et en tout cas avant diagnostic et
quand le diagnostic a été donné gagnant
anna et mots le l'étude pour cela a fait
ressortir que pour pouvoir rénover ça
faisait 5 millions 717 c'est un dossier
très complexe c'est ce que vous
expliquez que je vais dire si la mettre
en oeuvre
le dossier n'est pas difficile à mettre
en oeuvre le dossier constitue de toute
mise en place de projets il y a des il
ya des étapes et en arrivant à ces
étapes là je reprends l'église
aujourd'hui tout est en tournée voici
que on nous avons l'injonction depuis
trois mois de pouvoir atteindre qu'une
entreprise nous donnent eux nous fasse
faire un diagnostic de fouilles
archéologiques
donc c'est un élément important qu'il
faut retenir parce que vous faites on
est férié comme cela c'est pas comme
chez soi ou vers blaye et on va pouvoir
régler comme cela très bien alors vous
avez lors de votre récente présentation
de candidature lors d'une réunion
publique
vous avez indiqué que le premier mandat
à votre première mandature était
celle de l'installation des projets et
que vous demandez donc à nouveau la
confiance des green hornet et gros
mornais pour permettre maintenant de
passer à la phase exécutoire parce que
justement les chantiers sont multiples
les chantiers sont multiples il faut
résumer parce que j'étais sur une cible
nous avons le groupe scolaire qui permet
de pouvoir y loger sous peu l'école le
matin et de la fraîcheur
l'école mixte et l'école mixte c est
bien les 11 millions soit 104 1000e
aujourd'hui l'état prend tout en charge
mais sauf il nous faut avoir l'argent
vous payez bien nous avons lève dès
qu'ils ont fait confiance
parce qu'en fait ils ont vu que vous
faites au niveau financier nous avons
pas apporter des améliorations dans une
situation financière particulière qui
était dans la ville donc nous avons ce
projet qui est déjà pris en compte
nous avons le stade et des fastes du
sportif ça fait 2 millions que trois
millions quatre cent mille euros
eh bien ces éléments sont en avance donc
tout est ok mais on ne dément pas un
projet comme cela
donc les choses sont on lance et puis
nous sommes fin prêts pour les actions à
venir
merci gilbert couturier d'avoir répondu
à nos questions dans ce ca ou caddie
spécial municipal réalisé par claudine
était le miel
[Musique]